let's take a look at what it will take
to implement a very basic syncadapter
we're going to write two services each
service serves the primary purpose of
delivering an object that represents an
Android binder interface to one of the
system frameworks a binder is actually
the low-level glue that implements cross
process communication in Android you've
been using binders every time you talk
to an Android system service intense and
content providers are just high-level
abstractions on top of the binder
interface there's a whole language known
as a IDL to help define these interfaces
we're not going to cover all this here
but there's a lot more you can do with
services and binders one more thing
before we start we're going to define an
Authenticator service and an
Authenticator but it will only be used
by the Android accounts framework to
allow us to create an account sync
adapters need an account and the account
framework requires that there be an
Authenticator delivered by an
Authenticator service you'll see that
our authentic ATAR is just a series of
stubs with exceptions that get thrown
for each call just to prove that it
isn't really used one final note this
section approximately follows the online
training at developer.android.com around
syncadapters feel free to look there if
you have any more questions we're going
to create a new package sync to house
all of this goodness and a new class
file for Authenticator this code that
we're about to paste in really just
comes from the developer.android.com
website and as I mentioned earlier it's
just a stub you can tell because we
throw exceptions for calling any of the
functions except for the constructor and
one more file create Sunshine
Authenticator service this is more code
that is written for us it allows the
account manager to access the empty
Authenticator that we just pasted in now
we add the account type in our
strings.xml the account type string
suggest that it is specific to our app
if we add many applications using the
same account we might want to create
just an example comm account
we'll also begin to clean things up and
add a content authority string note that
this matches our content provider string
will fix the XML file later so they both
use this same string we create a new XML
resource file file named Authenticator
dot XML with root element account
authenticator and you probably notice
that sunshine Authenticator service is
actually a service that needs to be
registered with a package manager in
androidmanifest.xml here's the more
pasty goodness that does just that now
be very very careful these strings Hall
have to match precisely the error
messages that the system gives for
having incorrect accounts are not
necessarily intuitive and with that we
should be able to create valid accounts
once again this is all just to the
syncadapter can be tied to an account we
don't actually use this at all
all right let's tweak our provider tag
in the manifest we're going to add the
syncable attribute this just lets
android know that we're planning to
synchronize the content provider with
the server also will spent Android
exported equals false we had it at the
default setting which means that other
apps could see our content finally let's
change the authority to use our new
string now for some additional
permissions we need to be able to read
and write sync settings that make sense
we also have to authenticate accounts
even though we're not really using them
for anything
none of these permissions are ones users
should be concerned about but as
developers we always want to be careful
when we have to add new permissions
let's create the sunshine sync adapter
file itself inside of sync which extends
the abstract threaded sync adapter class
hit ctrl I and then ctrl o to implement
the necessary abstract methods and
constructor will use the first
constructor we'll fill this out later as
you may recall the sync adapter pattern
requires yet another service so we're
going to create a new Java class called
sunshine sync service this class is used
to deliver the sync adapter binder to
the sync manager the binder is
implemented for us by the abstract
threaded sync adapter class
and returned in the get syncadapter
binder method and now we need one more
XML file create sync adapter XML with
root element sync adapter once again
this XML file defines the settings
associated with our sync adapter
including its content Authority the
account type that it syncs whether or
not its user visible whether it supports
uploading which changes the way the
content provider interacts with the sync
adapter allowing parallel syncs and is
always sinkable these settings make
sense with this particular application
and I bet you know what comes next
you're right you have to register the
sync adapter service with the package
manager and therefore we have to create
more manifest entries containing some
important metadata most importantly
links to the file we just created all
right now we're getting close let's
start working on the sync adapter itself
we'll start with a helper function to
get the dummy sync account and make sure
that it has been created then we'll add
another helper function to our sync
adapter to make it easier to test our
sync adapter